So I have to start today with potentially
just a major, major scandal and the scandal
is the growing possibility that the Trump
administration is now lying about corona virus
case numbers.
And this is extraordinarily serious.
If true, this is potentially the Trump administration
doing what Trump attacked China for doing,
which China pretty clearly did do this.
This does not mean China didn't do it.
This would mean that China did it and now
potentially the United States is doing it.
So the number of cases appears to have flattened
in the United States since the exact day on
which hospitals were told, don't send your
data to the CDC anymore.
Send it to Donald Trump's Alex Azar, who runs
Health and Human Services.
And on the day that this happened is this
happened July 15th, 16th.
I said we now have to look skeptically at
a decline or leveling off in cases, because
now the reporting is going to the politicized
Department of Health and Human Services instead
of the CDC.
And even more stunningly, as I will show you
in a moment, a complete reversal in case trends
took place in the states that Trump won in
2016.
Exactly on the day that this change in reporting
took place.
So there's an excellent video on YouTube about
this by a guy named Jeff Hester, who goes
into a lot more detail than I will today.
I'm going to talk more about the political
implications, but we're linking to Jeff's
video in the description for this YouTube
video.
So you can see him lay it out.
But the gist of what's going on is that on
July 16, the first day during which data was
no longer sent from hospitals to the CDC,
but instead to the Department of Health and
Human Services, cases nationally started to
flatten immediately.
Now, without looking into this in more detail,
maybe it was a coincidence.
Maybe something was done policy wise.
Maybe there is another reasonable explanation
as to why cases seem to have been on an aggressive
upslope.
Up until this day and then right when the
reporting change happens, the cases level
off.
But what Jeff Hester then does is brilliant.
Jeff separates cases in states won by Trump
in 2016 and cases in states won by Hillary
Clinton in 2016.
And when you do that, what you see is stunning
cases nationally had been trickling up since
mid-June.
Now, it had been a slight uptick in the Hillary
states and a massive growth rate in the red
states, about three times the growth rate
in red states and blue states.
You had starting in mid to late June, up until
July 16, on July 16.
Nothing changes in the case.
Growth rate in blue states, just that continued
trickle.
And in red states case, growth actually goes
negative.
Forget about slowing growth.
They start to see declines in new cases in
Trump states.
I need people to really understand this on
exactly the day that the CDC stops receiving
data from hospitals and instead data goes
to HHS and then comes out from there.
HHS, run by Trump Tool, Alex Azar.
You have a reduction in the number of new
cases in the Trump states.
This is a completely believable slope for
blue states.
Just everything stays roughly the same as
slow growth.
And it is a completely unbelievable change
in slope in the red states, given what we
know.
We know that it takes eight to 10 weeks to
flatten the curve before you start seeing
a decrease in cases.
What you see as social distancing and mass
squaring and shutdowns work, you see the growth
rates start to slow down and that takes four
to six weeks.
Eventually, you hit a peak and then you see
the declines start.
So in this case, we see just a straight up
reduction in new cases in red states.
So there's the speculative part.
But I don't I don't want to get to the speculative
part quite yet.
First, let's just focus on what we know and
let's try to find other explanations, see
what other explanations we can come up with.
We have cases on a trajectory leading into
July 16, very, very large growth.
We have no real policy change on July 16th.
In any case, it takes a couple weeks to see
policy changes.
There were no real policy changes around July
1st.
And then on the day that the one thing that
does change is that data goes from hospitals
to HHS instead of hospitals to CDC.
We see that the numbers dramatically improve
in the red states.
Red state cases start to decline while there
is no change to the growth rate in.
Blue states, what explanations could there
be other than corruption and lying in the
red states?
Exactly as we predicted, this would leave
itself open to when we announced this policy
change weeks ago.
Well, maybe the red states are being more
cautious.
But that's not true.
Red states are being less cautious when it
comes to social distancing policies and masks
and so on and so forth.
And again, that change would have had to happen
weeks before to see the effect starting on
July 16th.
We can get into speculation about the weather
or humidity, but these things have been widely
debunked and they really don't explain the
data anyway.
And then you realize and then again, this
is still just fact for now.
They lie all the time.
That's just a fact.
They lie about crowd sizes.
They lie about hurricane maps.
That Trump modifies them with a Sharpie.
We have the most and best testing, 15 cases
will soon go
to zero.
Not necessarily a lie, but completely untrustworthy.
So
we have to consider that this is corruption
and these are fake numbers.
And it looks like we may well be lied to.
Well, you could say, David, you know, it's
weird because even if HHS is doctoring the
data, the CDC is reporting the same numbers
as the age as HHS.
Is the CDC also lying?
Well, as far as we now know, CDC is getting
their data from HHS.
In other words, yes, CDC and Johns Hopkins,
they're all reporting the same numbers because
the numbers are now going hospital to HHS.
HHS does whatever and then spits the data
back out, which is the data that everybody
else uses.
So that doesn't really prove anything or serve
as a defense.
So I don't have anything more for you today
in the sense that we need to figure out what's
going on here.
It is not plausible that you would see a reduction
in new cases this quickly in red states, given
what we know about policy, given what we know
about lag times and hopefully if there are
state level whistleblowers that will be able
to shed light into this, we will hear from
them soon.
And indeed, we must call out the corruption
and it exists.
But understand that if they're lying about
cases, they're going to have to lie about
deaths at some point because we know that
case spikes lead to death spikes.
And if you lie about only the cases, all of
a sudden your death rate relative to cases
is going to go way up.
So if they're lying about cases, at some point
they're going to have to lie about deaths.
Just not testing doesn't make this go away.
Not reporting deaths certainly doesn't make
it go away.
But for a desperate, cornered president who
sees himself as potentially losing to Joe
Biden, I would put nothing past him to try
to win this election, given that we've caught
him lying.
What, 20000 lies and misstatements per The
Washington Post?
Extremely disturbing.
And exactly as we worried would happen when
this policy change took place.